so my name is Dan Walsh I work for Red
Hat I actually my type my official title
is Li hua my jabra role is a consulting
engineer read that my title is lead
architect of the runtimes team at Red
Hat so we handle everything underneath
kubernetes and underneath OpenShift
needed to run containers so we have a
whole bunch of people working on our
teams and we've been developing a whole
bunch of really we should call and
container engines the the runtime term
is overused really what these are is
container engines and I see the low
things like run seeing cata containers
as being is really being the runtimes so
really these things are container
engines so this talk is called replacing
darker with pod man really what we've
our view of the world is actually
replacing tearing apart what docker did
into a series of sub components so pod
man really is replacing the docker CLI
so it's sort of the traditional way you
ran docker commands is what we're
looking for for what the pod man command
so first you DNF install I could have
put app get up here you DNF install pod
man then you do this any questions and
to show you that's true
this guy Alan Morin I who I don't know a
couple months ago said I completely
forgot that two months ago I set up an
alias of doctor who goes pod man and it
has been a dream no big fat demons
project atomic down below one of the
comments to him was how did you figure
out you were using pod man instead of
docker and he said I did I did Padma and
help all right a darker help and it came
up and gave him pod man's help message
so that's how we figured it out so
obviously I can't stop at that so at
this point everybody has to stand up if
you've seen me do talks before I make
you guys participate
okay so please read out loud anything
that is red excellent nice work
alright so alright containers is a Linux
thing or it's you know it's basically a
concept and do you guys go make copiers
and say I'm going to make a Xerox or do
you take a tissue paper out and say it's
a Kleenex or do you take an aspirin out
and say it's an aspirin oh that's a bad
point but basically in this conference I
cringe in the back of the room every
time I hear someone you know basically
use the D word and I actually have
another talk where I have a swig yeah
that I put up and every time I say the D
word I have to put money into the swear
jar but I'm not going to do that today
because I don't have much money but
anyways what do you need to run a
container okay what do I what is it what
is me when I run a container and the
first thing you need when you want to
run the container you need to identify
what the hell is a container and a
container in in this case it's been
standardized or at least the image
format or what people mean when they say
I'm gonna run a container and they're
talking about something that sits at the
container registry like docker i/o or
Quay dot IO or you know there's probably
a hundred different people out of
factory are all doing container
registries and there's these images or
tar balls that sit up there and
container images and a couple years ago
thanks to core OS if you saw the talk
earlier on Vincent stock talked about
you know sort of the history of
container runtimes core OS introduced
the app see spec caused a fracture all
of a sudden they're going to be two
different types of container images I
mean it actually forced all of the
companies the big companies that are
involved in containers like big
companies and startups to get together
and say we're gonna standardize on what
this is what it means to be a container
image and that's where OC I came out the
big companies I'm talking about Red Hat
IBM Google Microsoft darker core OS at
the time who we've now acquired as you
most do you know got together and they
standardized on what it means to be a
container image last year last December
actually that came
with the OCI image bundle specification
and now we sort of have a good idea of
what it means to be a container so I say
I want to run the Fedora container I
know what I'm gonna get when I pull it
down or have an idea of what I'm gonna
get so the next thing I need to do is
get mechanism for pulling images pulling
the images off of container registry to
the hosts and again some of this was
covered earlier this morning but
basically we built a tool several years
ago actually Antonio in the back of the
room did - we actually did a pull
request upstream because what we found
is that people were pulling images off
of container registries and they were
huge I mean we're talking some images of
1.5 gigabytes to gigabytes right these
are huge images is a JSON file that
basically describes what's in the image
so we said is why not why don't you
build a command like darker inspect - -
remote to pull down the JSON file
associated with the image that I could
then look at and then figure out if I
actually want to pull down the image
right the only way to get an image and
look at what's inside of it right now
is to pull it to the host you have to
pull that to gigabytes to your machine
before you face a oh that's not really
what I wanted let me get rid of it so we
went to upstream with that pull request
and they said sorry we're not interested
it confuses the API or the CLI too much
but he said they said but it's just a
web interface right these are just
container registries container
registries and nothing but web services
with tar balls are so it's all web
protocol so they said go off and build
your own tool to go out and pull down
the JSON and look at it with your own
tool so we built scope EO scope EO means
remote viewing in remote viewing in
Greek and that's why we have a Greek hat
and a telescope and so after we built
scope EO Antonio actually went off and
he started implementing more of the
protocols for polling registries so
instead of just pulling down the JSON he
also pulled down the image and he also
figured out he got you scoped it'll push
images in scope EO basically slowly
evolved into this really cool tool that
you can start to move images around the
environment and you don't have to be
root to do this so you can actually copy
off a one registry copy to another
registry without ever having pulled the
machine pull the image bundle to your to
your host
so it really evolved in a cool tool and
we were actually working with core OS
before we acquired them and we're trying
to get to convinced them to use scope EO
to move images in and out of rocket and
they said well we don't really want to
be exacting a tool why don't you make it
into a library so we created containers
image so containers image is a library
that now is working independently other
people are contributing lots and lots of
pull requests into to be able to move
images around ok so it's a really a base
level image the number one contributor
outside of Red Hat is actually pivotal
ok who's wondering whether that's
biggest competitors in the open ship
space but pivotal is using you know
basically containers image for moving
images and out of I think they call it
garden is there their source for that so
the next thing you after you pull the
image to the host you need to be able to
explode the image onto disk ok and
usually in an in Linux world or in a
container world we call the we use
copy-on-write file systems because
basically an image tends to be a layered
thing so you basically want to install a
layer of an image then you're going to
create another type of file system or
another mount point on top of it you put
the second layer and you put another
layer on top of it and to do that use
copy and file copy and write file
systems so when way back when when we
were started first out and to work with
docker Red Hat I'm actually Alex if he's
here somewhere did most of the work the
guy that's in charge of flat-pack now
basically introduced a whole bunch of
different types of copy and write file
systems into what was darker at the time
that was overlay FS butter FS device
mapper and so what we did is we took the
all that that code and we moved it into
an independent library so it was
independent from basically the upstream
darker project and and then we went
inside to evolve that library so all
these things are independent the next
thing you need to do so you could
basically you define an image we pull
the image to the host we still run at
the top of some kind of storage and then
we need a standard mechanism means what
does it mean to run a container well
luckily OC I standardized on that so the
OCI specification was the runtimes ii
specification was called a runtime
specification which basically says I'm
going
right a JSON file everybody has to
understand what that JSON file looks
like and then I need to basically launch
a program that reads that JSON file and
creates the container on the system akin
to all the container processes sets of
the cgroups security settings namespaces
right so that's the last part of running
a container on the system one other
thing we needed is we needed sort of a
monitor when I'm running a container a
container can just exit okay so when a
container just exited right it doesn't
know what's running in a container it's
just a process on the system so you need
something to actually watch that process
if the process exits you want to grab
its exit code and store it somewhere
okay put it on the system you actually
want to keep open the tty so the
connected to it because people going to
come to you and say hey what's going on
inside of that container so you need a
process that sits out there and sort of
monitor said and that's called con wand
all right so if you went to the earlier
talk by Antonio he talked a little bit
about con Mon and how it's used inside a
cryo but crime mana is a simple C
program that basically is the parent of
the container so it can parent to the
pit one inside the container it just
sits out there running till the
container exits caches catches a sick
child and then it exit well it basically
stores away some last minute stuff and
exits that means that any one of these
container engines they're going to be
talking about like try oh and like pod
man can go away right they don't have to
stay running on top of the container to
watch what's going on so there's a
little Kanban process out there running
did I skip ahead oh yeah I just
explained Kanban and CNI was up this
sorry about that someone should have
said that so CNI is basically a way for
it's an interface again introduced by
car OS that basically defines a network
protocol for the container engines to
set up networking so other people can
come in and basically get a plug-in
interface to plug in different kinds and
it's really heavily used inside of
kubernetes we use it inside a cryo we're
gonna be using inside a pod mod so
basically all different types of people
tooling can basically build a CNI
plug-in and then we can use it with
these tools so basically we have the for
building of the five five six building
that allow us to experiment with
different types of container engines and
we're not talking about a container
engine that is something that you talk
to and say pull me an image so I know it
in images pulls it down to the disks
puts it on the storage configures the
Runcie specification or this is a OCI
specification and then launches the
runtime saves data like what happens
when they you know container exits and
reports it back to the human so it's the
basically it's the human interface or
the tooling interface for running
containers so one of my problems with
docker is become a big fat container
daemon okay it's a become basically a
roadblock for innovation okay having to
have a daemon to basically launch
process on a Linux system just seems to
me wrong right everybody that runs the
docker CLI syncs to the container is a
child process of the client what's
actually happening is the darker program
client is talking out to the server
talking out to a daemon and they're
actually the process that gets launched
as pit one ends up being a child or a
grandchild in it of the darker daemon
not of your process that launches I'm
going to show you some interesting
things about that but what's also
happened is if you have only one way of
doing containers it stops all innovation
right if I want to do some special
things if I want to move those container
images around I have to go to the one
entity and say may I please do this and
they say that's not really an interest
in this upstream project so you get
denied so what I want by breaking it
apart we basically get the best of both
world all different tools can use all
basically can contribute to these
different components and also you can
start to build some interesting tools on
top of it so this talk is talking about
pod man so pod man means does everybody
here know what apart is all right in
kubernetes world kubernetes launches
pods they don't launch containers what a
pot is is a is a process on the system
that has one or more containers inside
of it so what they what kubernetes want
is they want to launch these
multiple is one or more processes all
walk together in the same namespaces and
then be able to move them around the
system if people came the other night it
was a there's been some talks that
talked about these sidecar containers so
you might have your primary application
and you might lock into it another
container in that second container is
basically monitoring the first container
basically figuring out whether or not
that container is Orbitz doing something
on behalf of that container I think
someone was talking the other night
about basically does all the
authorisation for it so the application
the primary application can do stuff and
not have to worry about authorization
it's just the sidecar container that
does it so kubernetes wanted this
concept where I could run more than one
container at the same time around the
environment and it just manages pods so
when we built pod man pod man's part of
our lib pod effort which is basically a
library to build pods and so we wanted
to build pod minutes tool for managing
pods and containers the environment but
we didn't want to do when we built pod
man was basically give you a brand new
UI or a CLI so we wanted to basically we
started out by copying the darker CLI so
to run commands inside of pod man it
basically uses pretty much the exact
same CLI that you use when you run
docker so if you find any darker command
of the world theoretically you should be
able to just substitute Padma in for it
so lastly before I get to the demo we
show this is the architecture and again
this is the same architecture that we
shown earlier same picture that was
shown earlier for creo so we have when
I'm running a pod I have a series of con
Mon so when I'm running pod man it's
going to go out and create this
environment so I have a con man that
runs so if I'm running a pod directly I
will have an infra container that
basically just holds open all these
namespaces and C groups and then I have
one or more containers and running
inside of it so pod man can run pods but
it also can run regular containers this
is so the traditional way you've run
containers so at this point we're going
to demo it by the way the icon here a
group of seals is called a pod so that's
where we got the
okay so there so first first we're just
going to do a pod man version we're
going to be writing pseudo to run into
this route and of course like any good
security engineer I don't have sudo
without password so here we go we just
launched this version 0.9 a pod man
so I'll Britain and go because that's
what the cool kids want to write in and
what the reason it's own I know is this
was what we've been releasing Padma on a
weekly basis so the the it's not 1.0 yet
and the nine stands for the month and
the 1 stands for a week so this is the
first week of September version of pod
man and so I'm going to show your info
to give you so it's using container
storage containers are stored in the
vial I've containers we basically have
some additional features up above you
probably scrolled off the screen but I'm
not going to go up because I'll probably
screw it up but it's running on top
overlay filesystem and some neat things
that we've added is actually this is
something different than dark are from a
security point of view we actually mount
all the devices with no dev by default
so even the images and that's showing
you that you can pass in special
overlays but this is all stuff that's
built into the container storage has
given us all sorts of new features that
we can take advantage of so I'm going to
cat out a darker file so we're about to
this is a darker file that I used when
I'm about to demonstrate right now is
actually pod man running a container
that has builder which is builder is
another one of our projects which is a
container it's going to run a builder
and build a docker file build based on
the top of a darker file inside of a
container without giving any privileges
to it so here we go with the demo gods
hope
believe this so it's going to pull down
Alpine image because that's the smallest
image available if you look at it we're
actually volume mounting in here I have
a my ball directory and volume mounting
it in I'm actually using SD Linux so
we're changing the label on it and then
I have I like my containers I'm bouncing
bounding that in sub I alive containers
so build our inside of the container in
this case is going to be writing so a
host directory in the system and then
I'm using a VF s so I've changed the
type of the storage and there it is so
it's now finished it actually built a
container image with no big fat demons
so there's no demons running on the
system there's nothing up my sleeves or
whatever basically I ran inside of a
container another container inside of a
lockdown container that basically built
an image now that image could actually
be pushed to a container registry all
without any special privileges so you
can imagine that when we talked about
cryo earlier you can actually use tools
like pod man and build inside of
containers that'll lock down so you can
actually run really interesting
workloads inside of a kubernetes
distribution this kind of shows it so
here I'm gonna actually I'm going to
show the image that was just built so
OOP that's interesting
it doesn't enjoy it but here we have I
pulled down an Alpine image it actually
had a couple leis that got installed and
then basically it ended up creating my
image I'm inside of it so clear that
screen so interesting thing here is one
of the things I get asked often when I
knew I must supposedly a security guy
when I go to customers customers are all
worried about their their engineers are
coming to them all the time and saying I
got to build a stalker thing I got to
build this darka thing and I have to get
access to the docker socket so the
darkest socket is running as root and
you can actually do things like da Quran
- - privilege - v / colon slash host
Fedora Giroud /host and boom I have full
root on the system it's actually worse
giving someone access to the darker
socket is that worse than giving them
sudo without a password because there's
no blogging as soon as I screw around on
your machine I can go and blow away that
container and as soon as I blow away
that container all the logging gets
eliminated from the system so what they
want to do is they want to be able to
use the darkest CLI on the system
without requiring Rouge so here we are
so I'm about to show you running pod man
without root so I'm going to pull an
image and again hopefully the network
stays up everybody that's doing a yum
update on the system please stop right
now so it's going to pull down an image
to the system usually this is very fast
but this network is
talk amongst yourself right so this is
Padma and running without route there is
no diamond out there and what happens
when I run pod man as a non root user it
actually creates the storage so instead
of the storage being out on vial I've
containers it actually ends up being in
home directory dot local / share /
containers / storage I believe okay so
actually I'm going to show you that I
just pull down an image to my system and
just for that shows you the images on
the host so if there's a lot more images
on the host there's only one image in my
home directory if I want to run the
container on top of so there I just ran
alpine container ran the LS command
inside of a container in my home
directory no root needed so what are we
doing to cause this so how are we
actually doing this we're taking
advantage to use a namespace which most
of you have never seen before or at
least had very little exposure to so we
actually have a tool under build up
called build around share I just want to
show you
it's basically puts you into a user name
space without being inside of a
container so I am right now I'm logged
in as Dee Walsh on the system that
process right near that now that's
showing you the route on the home
directory that's Dee Walsh okay so it
basically did a swap in turn so what
happens in the system is this is
actually a program going on here so if I
did ID right now you will see for as far
as its concerned I am running as root on
the system if I did a cat of proc
uid map you would see the mapping that's
going on inside of the user namespace so
if you logged on to fedora system and
probably a bunch who has the same thing
shadow utils now puts every user the
logs into the system it puts an entry
into Etsy sub UID and that's the sub G
ID that defines the mapping that is
available to the this user on the system
so my system you see as I said my UID is
thirty to sixty seven it Maps UID 0 to
that and it said there was one mapping
in the range then it says I'm gonna map
UID one to a hundred thousand and I'm
gonna do it for five hundred thousand
you IDs so that means in my home
directory now I can map five hundred and
one thousand you IDs I can create you
IDs from my own UID as well as 100,000
100,000 one 100,000 two all the way up
and those would be mapped to one to
500,000 inside of the container pretty
cool huh
it leads to some interesting problems
though I can create direct content in my
home directory that I can't delete after
I could do it unless I'm in the username
space if I exit the username space back
to my regular UID I have files in my
home directory that I can no longer
delete so I actually just wrote a blog
on this this past week
okay so Padma has some interesting
username space so username space has
always been this nirvana
for a container isolation I just showed
you how you can use it in a home
directory but would be really nice is if
I could use it on the system for
separating containers so if I run a you
know right now when I run docker or pod
man I'm using different selinux labels
for each one of them that gives me
isolation with user name space I want to
be able to isolate basically have this
container have this range of you IDs
have this container have this you
arrange a you IDs and therefore if I
broke out of the container
UID five five five thousand would not be
able to interact with UID 6000 on the
system right just like normal
UID separation the problem is reason
we've never used this using namespace
predates talker but up to this point
there's never been a file system support
for this so user name space has been
really really cool but no one's ever
used it so what we did with pod man is
actually we built since the file system
doesn't support it what we've done is
we're using we're actually toning files
underneath the covers to be able to make
username space work so here I'm going to
create I use the name space for UID 0 to
well starting at a hundred thousand to
five hundred thousand that just created
one container now I'm going to actually
look at it so one of the other things
we've done with actually guys from Susie
did this with this work when I run a
container the doctor had this command
called darker darker talk to show you
the processes running inside of the
container so we've actually used this
new library called PS go that actually
can do something really cool we can
actually show you the UID inside of the
container as well as the UID outside of
the container and this is a brand-new
tool bear new enhancement to pod man
that basically allows you to see that
inside the container it says I'm used a
route but outside of the container if I
actually looked at that process the pit
on that process it's running us a
hundred thousand matter of fact I'll
show you that right now so here we see
you know the sleep program that I
launched inside of the container is
actually running as a
and so if I looked outside the container
so now I'm going to run another
container and this time instead of using
a hundred thousand for the first process
I'm going to use two hundred thousand
for the first process so now I have the
container and if I look at that
container I'd see that I'm running his
route inside of the container and
running his route outside the container
and if I look in the system I will see
that one sleep is running as a hundred
thousand the other one surrounding this
two hundred thousand but from inside of
the container they both think they're
wrote what's happening on the filesystem
underneath we've taken the Alpine
filesystem we're actually toning it on
the fly and we have some really
interesting tools that we're adding to
make that joining faster and better all
all different okay so I talked earlier
about darker being this client-server
model where you exec a program on your
filesystem and it talks to a client head
talks to a server and that causes lots
of issues it causes things that we can't
do like things like SD notify right
everybody knows what system D does with
SD notify basically you're going to run
a process inside of a container and it's
going to call back to system D and say
I'm ready to receive requests well that
never worked inside a darker because you
can't get the SD notify is not a chat
the darker command inside of a system to
unify l-- it's talking to the darker
daemon away on the you know on a
different socket and that process is
saying I'm ready to docker it's not
saying it back to the darker client it's
paying back to the docket server so when
I'm going to show you is pod man this
actually does exactly what you think it
does so the way I do that is there's a
pro does anybody know what this login
UID is when you log on to a Linux system
what happens is there's a UID part of
your proxy process system system records
that you add an walsh right that you had
logged in this 3267
so this will show this on the system it
basically says I logged in as thirty to
sixty seven I can't change that I can't
become root I can do anything in the
system sudo anything else this login UID
tracks me there's no way for me to get
change that login UID once it's set that
means that the auditing subsystem can
record the fact that I did something
whether I always root
different use or anybody else but it was
Dan Wallace that did it so here we're
going to run a container so we're
running a container and the container is
basically showing you inside of the
container process right now it's running
is login UID Dan Wallace right it's
running it's 32 67 if I run docker it
shows that it's running as UID that
happens to be UID minus one okay because
that's an init system darker demon never
logged on to the system so if I do
something evil on the system it comes
back via docker it comes back and says
darker did something evil if I do it
through pod man it's going to come back
and say Dan Walsh did something evil so
what I'm gonna do here is I'm putting a
watch on that see shadow which hopefully
worked even though to show that oh it
says the rule already existed which is
good because I ran this earlier and now
I inside a pod man I am touching I am
trying to rewrite that's a shadow right
and if I do this down here I got trapped
shows that a UID D Walsh did something
to it see shadow now if I do it through
darker and it shows a UID on set did
something to it see shadow so what
that's demonstrating from a security
point of view Padma and executing a
command basically tracks that what the
user did on the system as opposed to
darker and this is why I say when you
give people access to the docker socket
it's more powerful than sudo because if
I go through sudo and I do something in
your system the audit system knows that
Dan Walsh did it so I've showed a little
bit of Padma and top features I'm going
to run a container I can see the selinux
label for your pardon me on top I can
see this is something that no one sees
when they run docker no one has any idea
these are the Linux capabilities that
are on by default when ironic quad man
so we bought it right shown people are
always asking what capability everybody
talks about capabilities what should I
drop what should I add well these are
the default lists that you get in almost
every container you run in the
environment
if you run trial we run with a lot less
right a lot of these
abilities are there just to be able to
build containers okay make no that's so
I can create device nodes if I'm running
containers underneath trial and
production I'm not expecting people to
build device nodes so we take it away by
default you don't get make note there's
a couple other ones that we get rid of
when we're running it but basically
there's different you know if you look
at running applications there's
different ways of running applications
in this case we need more privileges
because we don't know what you're gonna
do with pod man so we call a pod man for
a reason one of the things we want to do
is be able to manage pods what I've
shown you so far is basically all the
CLI that matches up with docker but here
we have pods so if I want to create a
pod I'm gonna use pod mean pod I'm going
to name the pod up and it's going to
create a pot in the system that actually
the the echo line there is wrong I
didn't fix that but don't worry about it
I'll make this all available and
hopefully clean it up so pardon me a now
I'm going to actually create another pod
and have trade a sleep pod but in this
time I'm going to tell it I mean I've
got to create a container but I'm gonna
put the container inside of the pod okay
so this is basically creating a pod
so I created a pod now I'm assigning to
contain it to the pod now I'm going to
create another container and assigned it
to the pod and guess what I'm gonna show
on the system okay these are all the
containers I I ran earlier but basically
right now it would have worked a lot
better I should have killed all the
containers but basically I am about to
start the pod the two containers I just
created to not create containers so at
that point now you should see two more
containers so you've seed containers
that just got second got created they
were created on the system but basically
they just stack status that goes up one
second ago so you can see when I started
the pod now I cited both of those
containers if I want to stop the pod now
this is actually a bug when I'm stopping
a container waits 10 seconds for the
container to actually exit if the if the
tool catches that and sleeps sleeps
actually catching it there's a bug in
pod man right now that it actually waits
on the first one before it sends the
signal to the second one so we actually
have to fix that so it sends the signals
to all of them
so it's going to wait about 20 seconds
so there we did it and we should be back
to three containers running on the
system and again be better if I killed
all the containers before I ran it but
basically it's running so that shows you
pods I'm running on the system if I want
to remove all the pods I can actually
force it to remove all the containers
that are created for the pod and now if
I list out the pods and back to zero
pods running on the system so that is a
real quick demonstration of some of the
features that you can do with pod ban so
let's talk about other things I've
mentioned some of this stuff early
essence a lot of people here are
interested in system D over the years I
came to system D cough couple years ago
and I gave a talk about the CTO of
docker versus Leonard and both of them
were being very hard on working together
neither so one of the things I did when
we build pod man as we wanted to have
proper system D integration into it so
proper you can just run a container that
has system D and it will just work on
the pod man without any modifications we
support as I talked about with login UID
and demonstrated we actually can do
proper st notify so we run a container
the container does st notify that
triggers all the way up into pod man
Padma and that reports a system D that
the container is up and running and
ready to receive actions we also do
socket activation so you can actually
put pod man into a container pod man
into the system and have system D
automatically fire it up and it will
pass down the socket down to the process
that's running on the system so all the
things we wanted to do with pod man is
we wanted to have some kind right now
it's written in go we wanted to have a
interface to it that was people could
use other than go so we added a remote
API for it so we wanted to basically say
well I can run pod man I can set up a
system D so I could activated pod man
instance and then have a API that talks
to it so we actually decided to use
violent so vile Inc is a API is
communication tool a library that we can
use to actually do socket activation and
communicate to a pod man running on the
system
I mean allows you to socket activation a
pod man and here's a unit file that we
provide so if you install Padma and you
will get a pod man it's actually IO pod
man
service file create a socket file and a
service file if you enable those then
you can start to run remote commence
with pod man so here we have a Python we
also provided a Python library that you
can build Python programs to communicate
with containers so you can do an input
this is showing importing a pod man and
it's listing
I think it's dumping information so this
is lumping the information about pod man
on the host but basically it's a full
API that you can communicate with python
via python to it we also have so we
built a program called pi pod man that
does all of the pod man commands but
it's all written a Python and the Python
command talks to the vile link through
violence to the server and so you can do
all of the Python that why did we write
Python command to do this because we
wanted to do Python on different
operating systems so here is a
demonstration of using PI pod man
hopefully this yeah you're not gonna be
able to see it but basically it's going
to run all the commands on the system so
it's basically doing PI pod man they had
to list the containers it's showing you
some of the config information showing
info that's the pod man info command
that I wrote so this is doing it all and
rather than since most people can't see
it the last step of this is it actually
shows this is all running on top of a
Mac okay so this is running a Python
script on top of a Mac that's talking to
a virtual machine that's running by link
into a pod man client sitting in a
system to unify oh so we built this
protocol to be able to talk from the Mac
to the server we called it SSH okay so
we take an advantage basically we built
we're basically taking an advantage of
eh on a Mac are on a Windows box or a
remote Linux box to actually talk to
violin over the system so if you have
all you have to do to make this work is
actually use SSH set up SSH to
communicate between the two boxes and
it'll work
we're adding cockpit support since we
have clients so this is this this is for
stuff so we're adding Padma and support
into cockpit sadly I have it running on
here and it didn't show any images so
I'm not going to show you that but
basically I have some one-man pits been
working to help us get this working but
basically we're getting full integration
between cockpit and pod men and in this
case we're using nodejs to actually talk
to the biolink protocol to applaud me
and running an assistant to you know
file now I say no big fat demons I'm
kind of cheating a little bit but the
thing here is that pod man is just
running for the connection that happens
okay so firing up multiple pod means
every for every single connection so
we're not doing any kind of monitoring
of you know multiple containers or
anything like that so what don't we do
what we don't do okay right now so I've
talked about us replacing darker but the
stuff that the darker demon did that
we're not doing inside a pod man so one
of the things we don't do is they don't
do auto reach that okay because there's
this thing called system D that does a
real good job of auto restart so if you
want a container that's going to be
restarted if it fails so blows up you
put pod mannequin net inside of your
unify and it just works we do don't do
darker swamp we work on kubernetes you
want a day if you want to orchestrate
lots and lots of containers use cryo on
top of kubernetes we don't do notary
right now okay but we'd be very willing
if someone wants to open up patches to
make pod man work with notary would be
very willing to do it ready that's
probably not going to put the
engineering into doing that we don't do
health checks yet okay Cal checks could
probably be done as a sidecar container
or they could probably be done in as a
system to unify l-- or like a you know
file weaker age basically a health check
is supposed to come out periodically
make sure that the container is running
properly on the system but we haven't
quite figured out how we're going to do
about that we don't do the dr. api so if
you have tools that talk the doctor api
to the docker demon
we don't have a tool for that lastly we
don't do daca volumes yet sadaqa book
volumes we do most of what you think of
regular volumes file system volumes but
there is people that have built dr. D
darker but demons for the darker demon
that do volumes we're looking at doing
that very soon so that's planned on the
roadmap to be able to support that this
point this is the real point where we
ask questions anybody have questions yes
Oh a lot of people have questions you're
gonna be running around so first think
in terms of the implementation of dr.
API there is one reason for doing that
maybe not in Putman instead what we can
just provide some wrapper on top of the
VAR link API because without that I
don't have integration in all of the IDS
IntelliJ whatever and without that I can
I am unable to get rid of the docker
from the developers or station because
what do you what do you need the e so
you're talking about like twist lock and
stuff like that no no no I mean the idea
of from the IntelliJ or Python or
whatever or Visual Studio code every ID
for the developer had resulting from
quorum to a root process launching Rob
booboo pro yeah I mean we wanted to
accept if people wanted to build
something like that on it I probably
would not be hugely it's not the scope
of the plan but yeah just an idea of of
wrapper right so that's one thing and
the second thing we get rid of the
docker on almost all places except one
docker file and write the darker file is
we still we support the darker file
format I might do we're doing a
I'll sign up for a lightning talk later
and I'll talk about bilder so I can do a
fivehead
so basically right now pardon me and
only supports docker file format builder
supports anything you want yeah for the
builder perfectly know that I can just
write simple shell script right and
create whatever I want but not everyone
should write shell scripts right the
goal of builder is not it's basically
allow you to build another tool like
like an stable container or source to
image and other people to build tools
that don't have to generate a docker
file in order to build an image but it
would be nice there why don't we let
other people to question out yeah I'll
talk to you forever outside okay just
yell
does footman's support a union of file
systems like AFS says yes it runs into
right now it supports overlay FS we've
actually we have a bug on device mapper
back-end so it supports overlay FS by
default we have a bug in device mapper
right now device mapper was built under
the concept that only one process would
do it but we have ideas to how we're
gonna fix it runs on top of butter FS
and I don't know if anybody's tested it
also BFS so VF s Slayer and someone's
built a overlay filesystem for so when
you're running in an non-root
environments it's actually using VF s
because you can't use overlay FS on it
but one of my engineers wrote a thing
called fuse overlay FS that actually
works real well for non-root so we're
actually introducing that to anybody
else yeah
get away one two okay yeah one of the
reasons I've still been using D and most
people decompose yeah so darker composed
I didn't put that one up
seems Leo could we've been asked about
that and again I'd be willing to accept
it we're thinking of that that's on the
roadmap to do some kind of compose and
whether or not we support the darker
composed language or we support a
kubernetes composed language or we
submit support an open shift compose
language again pod means a fully open
source project so anybody that wants to
contribute is welcome to contribute and
we will take patches you know for that
but right now we don't have compose yet
anybody else
Oh up here I mean it's actually plus-one
for the API because ansible arounds via
API the D Ward service API Oh
so without that we ansible yeah well I
mean we're working at you mean ansible
container ah so I'll seem to contain the
wrong yeah ansible containers with
they're looking into moving directly to
bought part to build up for first
support for that for that thing so to
get out of basically get out of the
darker team I mean right right now
everybody's that in my opinion
everybody's basically put the darker
socket all over the place the darker
socket is one of the most dangerous
things you can do as soon as you give
the darker sake you give full route to
use system without having any tracking
and most of the time you're doing that
to do darker bills right and so usually
you're basically given you contain your
people the ability to create a darker
file and then build it into an image
well I just showed you that you can run
in fact you can run pod man non-root
with builder inside of a container and
actually build a docker image and push
it to docker i/o and I just said darker
image so I owe money oh yeah
a container image I blew it that's I
think the first time I really screwed up
okay anybody else all right except
probably I'm out of time anyways I've
been
[Applause]